Okay,
here's an interesting story.
An amendment was made to the clean air
act in the United States,
aimed at reducing the release of carbon
monoxide into the atmosphere to reduce
air pollution.
Part of the law mandated that gasoline
and automobiles must have a minimum
amount of oxygen at additive.
A chemical compound that helps fuel burn
more completely in this limits the
certain carbon monoxide released into
the atmosphere from 1992 to 2005.
The most popular oxidative for gasoline
was methyl,
ethyl,
ether or Mtbe,
but in the early two thousands,
the number of cases of mtbe
contaminating groundwater raised
concerns about its health effects.
Gasoline additive mtbe was first noticed
in the water in 2000.
One residential reportedly got sick from
drinking it,
2004,
both New York and California banned that
chemical from the state.
A big blow considering Kelly and and why
accounted for 40 percent of nationwide
mtbe consumption.
A year later in 2005,
23 more states followed suit and band
that chemical.
In that same year,
Congress passed the Energy Policy Act,
which did not include provisions to
shield MTB manufacturers from those
pesky water contamination lawsuits,
and so with no protections against
growing public outcry,
the country was forced to turn to
alternative ways of gasoline
oxygenation.
What filled the void was ethanol in the
last 10 years,
ethanol manufacturer and consumption has
risen like a rocket ship in 2010.
The US was the world's top ethanol
producer with 13 point 2 billion gallons
or 57 point five percent of global
production.
Ethanol is a biofuel,
which means that it's a fuel produced
from living organisms.
In the case of America,
the majority of ethanol comes from corn.
The increase of demand for ethanol
driven in part by US legislation to
reduce air pollution has led to the
widespread expansion of crop land to
produce more corn,
especially in the Midwest and Great
Plains right smack Dab in the middle of
the monarch butterfly migration path.
Whoa.
The butterflies dude,
indigenous to North America and
instantly recognizable to anyone who
lives here.
The monarch butterfly,
it makes the longest and most
spectacular migration of any insect in
the world.
Every winter the monarch population
flies 2,500
miles from its many homes in America and
Canada to specific warm sites in Mexico
and Southern California on the way it
lays eggs for the next generation,
but it can only lay them in one place.
Milkweed plant.
It's an odd feature of nature that
monarch larva eat milkweed leaves and
nothing else,
but they do and as much as monarch
larva.
Love that.
Milkweed farmers hate it.
It's a week we'd reduce yield and less
yield means less money.
So in addition to clearing pristine
lands in the great plains where milkweed
thrives,
farmers have increasingly adopted
genetically modified crops which are
resistant to herbicides like roundup.
To introduce you to round up quick pro.
This product is produced by Monsanto.
It is a post emergent nonselective
herbicide.
Naturally,
this poses a serious danger to the
population of the monarch butterfly,
which has fallen a mindblowing 90
percent since its peak in 1996.
The losses of milkweed are only part of
the reason why the monarch population is
crashing,
illegal deforestation of their winter
home in Mexico and a couple of years of
bad weather have hurt their ability to
make the long journey south and north
again,
but even when conditions are right,
monarchs now have to fly farther and
longer to find places to lay their eggs.
Often they die before making it there.
No one is talking about the extinction
of the monarch just yet,
but a 56 percent loss of monarch
population in one year,
2013 is nothing to sneeze at.
Both America and Mexico have pledged to
do what's necessary to save the monarch,
and if you want to help,
you can learn how to build butterfly
gardens in your backyard.
I don't know about you,
but to me this is an amazing story.
A story of the unintended consequences
of human action on earth.
Legislation passed in the US years ago
to fight pollution has come to pose a
serious longterm threat to one of
nature's loveliest creatures.
It's certainly a cliche to say
everything in nature is connected,
but it is.